ha llegado el momento del matrimonio
igualitario en nuestro país con estas
palabras sorprendía al presidente
sebastián piñera tanto a su bancada como
la posición al anunciar que el proyecto
de matrimonio igualitario que en chile-
lleva años dormido en el congreso será
retomado con carácter de suma urgencia
esto fue muy destacado por algunos
sectores de la oposición para algunos
fue la única cosa positiva de este
último discurso en el que el presidente
sebastián piñera también pidió perdón a
las personas a las que las ayudas
sociales por la pandemia llegaron de
forma tardía y anunció la creación de
una unidad especializada en derechos
humanos dentro de la fiscalía que estará
a cargo de investigar y poder sancionar
de la manera adecuada las violaciones a
los derechos humanos ocurridas durante
el estallido social de octubre de 2019 y
en los meses posteriores el presidente
también anunció que se incrementará la
financiación del instituto nacional de
derechos humanos que jugó un rol
fundamental en perseguir y denunciar
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
son las líneas más destacadas de la
última cuenta pública de sebastián
piñera que se realizó este martes desde
valparaíso y en el que repasó
lo que han sido los hitos de su mandato
y también anunció cuáles serán sus
prioridades para lo que le queda por
delante apenas diez meses de gobierno de
su último segundo mandato